stand by is the nickel committee ready
great letting them in now connected
there she is hello jane hi
hello beth hi bernard how are you i'm
well how are you
oh my so many people i'm jennifer yeah
nelson i'm the chair of the nichols
fellowship committee
and i'm here with other members of the
medical committee who read your script
you have won a nickel fellowship
[Laughter]
[Music]
my gosh wow
okay i just stopped having a panic
attack no thank you gosh
thank you so much this is the best news
i've ever received
sorry uh it feels like i just got kicked
in the brain
oh i have a bounty i have paper towels
in my armpits
i can't even describe it it doesn't feel
real
feels very validating to compete with
some great writers
thank you for recognizing my father that
is the biggest thing
this is such a meaningful thing coming
from the academy and
from all of you just keep writing and
writing
one day you're heard thank you for
hearing
me thank you for your work and good luck
have a great rest of your day and stay
safe
wow
oh crap i'm still on i'm gonna go bye